up in the sky it's a bird it's a plane
it's a cow for Hawaiian cattle Farmers
this is often the best way to get herds
to slaughterhouses on the mainland okay
not exactly like this they use jet
planes retrofitted to make room for all
those cows but it would be cheaper and
easier to ship them on well chips so why
don't they because of the Jones act a
103 year old law that severely limits
which ships can be used to transport
goods from one American Fork to another
if you want to move surfboards or
pineapples or cows from Hawaii to the
West Coast you can only use a boat built
in the U.S registered in the U.S owned
by an American company and operated by
American Sailors sounds patriotic right
wrong by excluding ships built elsewhere
around the world the Jones act limits
competition and Hikes costs and as a
result your stake and a lot of other
things you buy get a little bit more
expensive